I was sleeping
because it was something like 2:00 in
the morning but in California
I was very who bob was this thing and so
I was very surprised it was very amazing
how quickly things happened because
you're in handsome he's who's the chair
of the selection committee he said he
said the press will be calling you in 15
minutes I advise you to drink a cup of
coffee and the press showed up you know
in our street and there was this trucks
with big television you know satellite
dishes you know to something in the
morning so at some point at when things
quiet and down slightly I said to her
neighbors I said what did you think you
know did you think we'd murdered
somebody or
[Music]